stream comments so i can see it
are women destroying the image of
marriage
women man for the wrong reasons
uh
i'm gonna answer it this way i think
that
the
rom-coms in hollywood has destroyed the
image of marriage
um disney has destroyed the image of
marriage so it doesn't surprise me that
women are marrying for romantic love
um
[Music]
romantic love and and that kind of stuff
um
so sadly so many of our women
are marrying
for true love and in my opinion
that's the wrong reason because that's
not what gets you through
once i actually sat down and talked to
somebody
i became a proponent because you learned
coping skills and and ways of
communicating
uh that i you know that that i never had
before and then you can use them as as
necessary how many times people watch my
show and say damn you're a better one to
me g
i couldn't do that
yeah it's a learned thing
um
does he mean like coping to talking to
people that are like unruly
also let me know guys is this audio
level okay i think one of the major
things is
is especially in the black community we
are so christian
we really believe that we're not being
faithful to god
uh
if we if we go to uh
if we go get counseling but i say god
made counselors too
um
that's why i'm i if yeah i'm big on that
man
uh especially for black men
because um we just had a young rapper
kill himself right a little loaded
look you know our culture is different
we're quicker to jones on you
than uh
didn't say i hear you but there's
sometimes if if if
jr called anton
and there's sometimes you can hear
something in a man's voice
when he hit that that crack you know
what i mean that crack
he's like
hey man
i you like
i'm on my way fam
you know you got to get to your homeboy
and quick
because there's maybe a loaded 45 and a
ball of jack on the table
and we got to learn do you guys feel
like men aren't able to express their
feelings because sometimes
i think that guys are like afraid to
express their feelings because they're
afraid like one the girl isn't gonna
like them anymore and like two
that
other guys are gonna make fun of them do
you guys think that's a thing um
obviously
i'm like i talk to girls more than guys
so i wouldn't know
learn how to
extend some grace to one another as men
because black men in particular don't
have a lot of outlets and we aren't
necessarily comfortable
uh
sharing um
personal stuff with with each other
because
you know like it or not
we we don't want it to get out right
but the more we start dealing with
therapy the more we start understanding
that you know that there are some things
that are out of bounds per se
and and allowing folks to be human man
we're going to be better off because
i i think
you know this is my personal opinion i
got nothing to base it on but i look at
what we survived as black people and if
you put that on any other race of folks
i don't know
could they have made it to where we are
the fact that we are still breathing
is amazing
but um i think it's important for
brothers in particular
because we don't get enough validation
and support and affirmation and we got
to learn to get out to each other i'll
say this now get a mic up uh oftentimes
i have a young brother
he doesn't even know he wants to give me
a compliment but he didn't know how
you like i like instead of saying like
the way you dress like this that's the
saddest thing i've ever heard in my life
you don't know how it's like
that you'll be sliding i don't know what
that mean but that's just not
i don't know what that means either and
it reminds me of what i
and what it reminds me of is it reminds
me of when with all my college education
everything else i still lacked
the emotional vocabulary to express a
feeling
that that's that's dangerous especially
when you put testosterone
in it
hey man i just wanted to tell you i
appreciate that balance that you added
this is the side of kevin samuels that
you don't
hear too many people talk about like
you always hear about him
kind of being an [ __ ] right or being
very direct very
rude but people don't really talk about
how
empathetic and how he does preach things
like mental health and like
therapy for men and he really does have
that like empathy for people but
sometimes you don't it doesn't really
come across a lot of the time because um
[ __ ] did a show the other day
i'm a little loaded
up
man
and they took it down but the most
impactful show i saw of his and
one of the things you know that i
constantly say on this show is that
we're real people have a real
conversations of real time about real
stuff and what you just touched on is
what he talked about too is about being
your brother's keeper and it don't make
you weaker or soft if you in a moment
you got to have that moment but we got
to be there for our brothers um to
prevent situations like little lotus so
i do appreciate i really really
sincerely appreciate you adding that
balance fam thank you
and that's the thing japan's a friend of
mine
and you know i would say i've been there
for some a friend of mine i had to sit
up for days with a brother but but you
also have somebody can do that for you
and see
with with that comes a re-establishment
of
brotherly bonds
of people that you're not necessarily
genetic
dna related to
and trust
see
what gets us as a community is
we don't trust each other
we don't we're not well that's like the
one
when you open up to someone you always
run the risk that one they're gonna tell
other people like what you said right
and then other people are gonna look at
you differently you also run the risk of
you know them making fun of you or like
not really giving you like empathy um
so i i could definitely see like why
people don't trust each other sure we
can trust each other and and i get it
that's why i have a firm policy
i don't beef
and i challenge you this and and i don't
talk
i am like a vault
you tell me something it ain't never
gonna get out
now there's a machiavellian principle of
men
who want to be powerful collect favors
and secrets but there's also just a code
somebody who talks to me
know
that they ain't gonna get out and you
can play game telephone me if you want
you can play a game of power if you want
to tell me something tell three other
people it ain't never gonna get out of
me and when somebody can tell you
something and no it's not gonna get out
even
in the worst circumstances
you both benefit because they they still
have to have a begrudging amount of
respect for you even if that's jordan
peterson talks about that's why the
marriage like the benefit of marriage
just to have someone that you can just
tell the truth to all the time and you
can't leave
but now it's so common to like leave
that it kind of changes things but like
the idea of marriage is you there's
someone you can tell the truth to 100 of
the time and they won't leave if they
can't stand you
kev i got a question for you before you
did real quick
um so
i'm very careful when it comes to
aligning myself with certain people i i
i rock with people i give them shout
outs and stuff like that
but it seems as though
even though the manosphere is growing in
a positive way overwhelmingly and it's a
lot of people doing a lot of great
things
um you know i kind of pay attention to
how things sometimes go off the rails
depending on who's popping and who's not
at the time you know what i'm saying so
i guess my question is how do you
determine who you lend what platforms
you lend your voice to
like how do you balance that how do you
figure out
or how long maybe do you
watch and evaluate whether or not you
want to rock with somebody and and you
know how do you determine
whether or not you really align it with
somebody
versus being able to kind of have that
insight or that intuition
of people that's just doing stuff just
for the sake of
popularity or using your name or using
your platform or
using your voice and is not necessarily
in a positive way or it's not
it's not necessarily coming from a good
space but it's based off of
the fact that you are supporting a lot
of different people and a lot of
different platforms in a lot of ways
because you are a good hearted
well i know
i i work with people on different levels
but i'm really careful who i allow close
to me because um
like you i work
i work and i watch see one thing o'shea
will tell you he always says that people
don't recognize how much work i do
behind the scenes and how much i'm
watching
and i'm always watching so
um
[Music]
i will lend my support
to somebody who agrees on the basic
fight on the basic message but i also go
back and look at what they said in the
past
to make sure
that there can be a middle ground there
um always going to be
can it help get the message out to a
greater audience
uh
and and be in the form of some kind of a
hypocritical do no harm
this is why also
um i'm kind of hesitant to go places
because i'm not necessarily sure
if the outcomes that person wants lines
up
with what i want but i but i will say
this in general i look at the brand
and the brands align and the brands can
align that's okay but when i say that
i'm not just looking at my brand and
that brand i'm looking at my brand and
your brand
and jr's brandon and courtney's brand
and rila's brand and kate's brand
everybody i touch
just like
will be touched by everybody i've
touched in the past
so i can't necessarily work with
somebody here
even if it's lucrative
because that will bring it into
the ecosystem of yeah that's
that's something you have to think about
being like a content creator the people
that you associate yourself with
then you become associated with them so
you you kind of have to be careful
who you do collabs with and like do
different content creation stuff with
other people
so if you so i can't be like you got
dirt over here on the you got some shady
stuff over here where i can't have that
necessarily reach over here and is it
perfect
no
uh what i will say is
you're trying to work with the people uh
who are serious uh that's one thing i
try to work with people who are serious
and consistent in trying to do this full
time
um and i've had to make that a firm
requirement in 2021
that if you're not a con if you don't
don't have a consistent broadcast time a
consistent platform consistent mess
consistent this
then i i'll just wait until you get to
that point
and then from that point you know i try
to do as much as i can to help
lend my
what i can bring to a platform but i
still look at myself as a content
creator
uh i don't i mean yeah i'm hot right now
that's cool but it'll be somebody else's
turn but you got to always pay it
forward you know you don't ever want to
get
too big to where you can't still
buy with folks who are not where you're
at yet if you're if you're a fan of uh
you have to be a fan of the man but
rudyard kipling
if you can walk with kings and not lose
the common touch
that's big for me because i understand
that
my
my persona could come off as bougie
elitist
arrogant
standoffish he does a little bit i'm not
even gonna lie this six foot full
college time for it and suit this that
uh who is this but then you walk up to
me and i'm like what's up man how you
doing they're like oh [ __ ] you nicer
than i thought i'm like i ain't fried
chicken tuning in
and we're the only group in america
that's like that to where
in our barber shop you can have
[Music]
the the um the the the dude that cuts
yards for a living no disrespect to
dudes to cut yards and
a guy whose vp emerges in the
acquisition of goldman sachs and we all
get our hair cut at the same place
we're one of the only we're the only
culture to where all of our
all our people kind of mix that way
that's unique that's actually really
true because
like
if i go get my hair cut
like it's a different it's a completely
different group if you go to like i've
been to a five dollar haircut place
before and i've been to like a bougie
haircut place
honestly i don't even notice much of a
difference
but yeah i think he has a point
and it gives us an opportunity okay
someone in the comments said
your insert screen is larger than theirs
i can hardly see theirs i prefer you big
and the size of the screen because i'm
trying to ask if you guys prefer me big
or small on the screen um do you guys
like the size of this right here
um like the screen so i can make it
bigger smaller i want to make it
so like the angle is good so let me know
in the comments the insight that other
people don't because other folks they
separate
um
but i also say this that
for those of us who are trying to do
great things
you can't take this [ __ ] personally
we put out too much content we're too
visible
we're too seen
and if somebody wants to they can find
anything
six months ago you said
you're right
five months ago you was wearing a red
hat and you said
you didn't say we you said we are you
didn't say word you said all right you
got me this can't take this [ __ ]
personally
that's the thing about being a content
creator is you have to pay so much more
attention to what you say and this is
probably one of my flaws as a content
creator
so i just kind of talk i'm not gonna lie
to you
um okay i'm watching a lot of your
videos i like the other screen bigger
um let me know in the comments keep
telling me if you like me big or the
like which way you like it
i do do music reactions the lot and the
lives are
they're like brand new i'm i just got a
new computer and that's why i've been
having all the audio issues i've been
trying to set up my new computer
um but it like actually
is a fast enough computer to do lives on
so these are going to be regular i just
have to figure out what schedule i want
to do so this is kind of just a test
hey care before you go
and this could be the last question
but
um before you came on we spoke about
women marrying for the wrong reasons
and the question i posed was are women
destroying the image of marriage
are women destroying the image of
marriage
women for the wrong reasons
uh
i'm gonna answer it this way i think
that
the
rom-coms in hollywood has destroyed the
image of marriage
um disney has destroyed the image of
marriage so it doesn't surprise me that
women are marrying for romantic love
um
[Music]
romantic love and and that kind of stuff
um
so sadly so many of our women
are marrying
for true love and in my opinion
that's the wrong reason because that's
not what gets you through
do i fault them per se
no
i think you see courtney you can see she
looks kind of sad
i think she regrets not staying with her
baby daddy that's the message that's
pumped out big but um but what i
am hopeful is now that we have people on
the airwaves that folks can get the
message when i say f and i actually
agree with that i think marriage is a
lot more of a choice
than
i think it's a lot more of a choice than
like love because
if you get married let's say you do what
everyone wants to do you get married for
50 years right that's the goal right you
want to be married to someone forever
not many people can actually do that
if you do that
you don't think there's gonna be a year
or two when you don't really like the
person just like i don't know common
sense
they're probably gonna be times when
you really aren't a fan of the person
you're with but
i don't know that's just life i i think
it's more of a choice that's just my
opinion love i don't care about love
starting to hear more people say hey man
maybe we should go back to an arranged
system or this or that
because um
that's what it really comes down to
um
i've been saying
that i would be cool with a um arranged
marriage for years
although i don't know if my parents
sometimes i like i i could see the value
in why people do that you get to the
point of marrying for
outcomes legacy
then we're in a better position uh and i
think we have to and that's why i'm also
a big proponent of blackmail media run
by black men four black men we have to
redefine
a lot of things
from a male-centric standpoint
okay if we say women are getting married
for the wrong reasons
let's take that
what are we going to do about it
if the wrong reasons benefit the enemy
or somebody else
there's money in it that we got to do
something different now don't we
so we want women to marry for the right
reasons
we got
to put the right reason out there in our
own voice
okay
that's actually a really good point um
so oh my gosh the one thing that is
interesting about kevin samuels and i
don't really understand about him he
always preaches
he always always always preaches that
like you should get married st mary did
the like mother of your kids father of
your kids you met your husband and blew
it whatever but
he he didn't stay married he's only been
married like three years up and he's
like 50.
which i mean it's fine i understand like
i understand i just he clearly could get
married if he wanted to
so it doesn't really make sense to me
that you're gonna preach and tell people
to get married and stay married and
that's the way to do it if you're not
going to do it yourself you know
um
just my two cents though
okay this was kind of like a test stream
like i'm just testing this right now
could you let me know in the comments
how i'm gonna i'm gonna see if i can
like
can i rearrange the screen live
oh okay cool
i can okay let me know how you think
would be the best like way to put the
screen
i can make it a little bigger and go
like this
um
sorry if this is boring but i need to
know i need this feedback because i
could
it's more like he asked them if they
want to be married and they say yes
that's true
uh i could put it more this way
so i could even go even like further
back and go like this
again this is just like a
test right now
and then what would you guys want to see
in like shows if i did like a live show
weekly or something what would you guys
want to see
because i'm trying to get like a
consistent schedule but i need to know
what okay you guys that's too big for
you
okay more of me
and then i could put this a little
closer to me wait
okay
um
but if i did a show what would you guys
want me to talk about or see like would
you want
i'm just trying to get like a live like
the reactions
um
so you guys still think the screen is
too big okay let's see
i don't know how to crop it out right
now so the top is gone but i'm gonna
figure out how to do that
um okay i would like
to to bring on blue-pilled women and
call them out on their hypocrisy it
would be fun watching you destroy oh my
gosh
oh
i don't know if i'm the right person for
that
because i'm a lot i'm not like kevin i'm
not super dirt like i'm not super
like i'm usually pretty
non-confrontational a little bit but i
could test it out and see if you know
it's any good
because
fresh and fit reactions are good maybe
alexander wait grace
um
okay so you wanted me to do like live
reactions
kevin
is a weird situation he states he lives
by
mgtow what does that stand for
i think i should know that but i don't
um but he hates on
mgtows he's a walking hypocrisy
i mean i think he lives like some of the
stuff he preaches about i just i just
noticed when i found out he was only
married for like for three years
and he preaches that he could get
married and he wanted to if he wanted to
and says
that marriage is like the way people
should go
um
but he's not married himself that's a
little bit where i see
a bit of the hypocrisy coming in
but
i mean everyone is a hypocrite on some
level in my opinion
like if you talk to the average person
they genuinely generally
preach one thing they don't do i would
guess
okay what else would you guys want in a
show
i'm just trying to talk to you guys on
this live
sorry if this isn't super
you know
uppity um
so we only listen to slim doctors that
don't smoke i actually have a rule on
this i don't go to dentists with bad
teeth and i won't go to an overweight
doctor
um if you can if you don't do
the stuff that you that you say that you
know about it doesn't make sense for me
like genuinely i believe that so yeah i
wouldn't go to a doctor that smoked i
wouldn't go to a doctor that was
overweight i wouldn't go to a dentist
with bad teeth
i wouldn't
i wouldn't go to an overweight trainer
it's like the same thing
like genuinely that's all the same thing
okay
what you like about watch a show full of
fresh and fit and
dissect the shows like a check on the
behavior and stuff like that okay
cool
i'm just i'm trying to get like a
schedule put together and i'm just
trying to get ideas for it
maybe i'll make like a post or something
i'm going to react to maybe one more
video
if you guys have one you want me to
react to
i'm so happy this took me like three
days to get this audio i'm so bad at the
equipment guys so bad
terrible actually
when you go to a therapist that's not
crazy of course yeah and that's what i'm
saying
you would not
you would not want to go to someone
that doesn't practice the stuff
themselves that's why you know that's
why sometimes i'm a little bit hesitant
to give dating advice
genuinely like i'm genuinely hesitant
because i'm not married
and i genuinely believe to give dating
advice you should be married
um
so
like like to be like genuinely taken
seriously
um because
if you date you have the intention of
getting married so that's why
i'm like somewhat hesitant to do that
you know um
i've seen a successful marriage but
like i've never been in one
um okay do we link videos in the chat um
just give me the title and i'll search
it
well i'm married most married people are
miserable
i have not found that most married
people are miserable maybe most married
people that you know are miserable but
the married people i know tend to be
happier
than the single people i know genuinely
the people that get married have kids
and stay married in the long run i've
seen be happier
than the people that i know that got
divorced
or never got married
i think
on some level we all respect people that
get married and stay married
red pill black pill purple pill all this
stuff is usually
norm
normies so they label him i don't
know that
most married people are miserable at the
end of their marriage
well
but see that's he said most married
people are miserable at the end of their
marriage so if a marriage ends of course
they're gonna be miserable near the end
duh
okay
okay i'm gonna end this live